Bobby and Caitlin are going on a trip on
the second to the finals of the Miami
open the women's finals
Tick Tock star Bobby Moody has died by
Suicide he was 46 years old
Bobby's family shared the news in a
statement posted to tick tock featuring
a series of photos of Bobby with his
wife Jennifer whom he married in 2004
and their three kids Caitlin Max and
Charlie
okay
the family calls Bobby a loving husband
father brother and friend before
revealing that he took his own life on
April 28th Bobby was full of life and
laughs but also weighed down by
Financial pressures they add he was in
an emotional and financial crisis but
through it all Bobby was their Rock in
the caption his daughter Caitlyn calls
her father her best friend he had such
an impact on not only his family but
those around him
we're gonna play catch
he was and is still so loved by so many
he will forever be remembered
the Mississippi content creator had more
than 360
000 followers on Tick Tock where he
shared moments with his family
according to his obituary Bobby had a
successful career in sales for more than
20 years on April 26th two days before
his death Bobby posted his final video
featuring his daughter Caitlyn doing
what he called an imitation of annoying
Baseball fans
oh my goodness go team
shut the hell up
be quiet a GoFundMe page has been set up
by a friend to support his family